après une réaction jugée tardive à
l'épidémie de coronavirus le royaume uni
fait face aux premières graves
conséquences de la pandémie
le nombre de malades explose en soins
intensifs alors que le taux
d'absentéisme du personnel est compris
entre 30 et 50% des effectifs
une première historique pour pallier le
manque de lits et éviter un scénario à
l'italienne ce centre de conférences de
la capitale londonienne est en ce moment
reconvertie en hôpital de campagne
cent mille mètres carrés pour accueillir
4000 lits supplémentaires d'ici à la
semaine prochaine
de quoi convaincre cet ouvrier et
employé sur le site de la gravité de la
situation et michael cai voler des
câbles pour cet hôpital ne prend pas ce
virus au sérieux jusqu'à ce que je vois
ça dans un premier temps le gouvernement
de boris johnson avait choisi une
réponse jugée timorée par de nombreux
observateurs
mais lundi dernier changement radical de
cap avec un confinement nationale
décrétée pour au moins trois semaines
boris johnson a aussi soumis aux députés
britanniques un projet de législation
d'urgence objectif donner aux autorités
des pouvoirs extraordinaires comme des
arrestations à des fins de santé